[Music]
[Music]
when the sky roars I climb to the top
[Music]
the sensations ow
cool drops felt against
the chill sends me into a kind of giddy
[Music]
the clouds left
warm rays permeate the canopy
[Music]
muddy river banks black in my paws
fog voices and beads in my hair
[Music]
we call the forest home
[Music]
faint smells guide me on a constant
search for food
I traced the musty odour of a soft log
to termites I didn't always walk the
forest alone I had a mother and brother
once we used to rip open bogs and dig
for earthworms together but one day
mom's foot got stuck in a snare I was
off eating fruit when I heard gunshots
ricochet through the trees I saw my mom
leave the forest and a bag that day and
my brother in a small metal cage the
whirring of bees always reminds me of my
mother
she described honey as being the
treasure of the forest no matter how
high
I'll always climb for it
I'm alone now but there are others
sometimes I try to mock fight with them
like my brother and I used to they don't
understand me though
i pile branches and damp leaves until
the moonlight fills the cup of my nest
my eyes fall to a close on the sand of
peaceful off an unfamiliar racket
interrupts the morning choir an
orangutan sounds his alarm an intruder
[Music]
after weeks the noise finally stopped
but I was replaced with the smell of ash
[Music]
it's the ones who took my mother and
brother
[Music]
away the only place we all call home
[Music]
and replace it with endless rows of
strange trees
[Music]
the forest is too small now fruit is
scarce I am forced to leave or starve
[Music]
but can I live here with all the men and
roads
[Music]
I enter a form of hysteria when my paw
gets stuck in a snare like what happened
to my mother
because this where they took my brother
their new smells here but I can't get
out to find them
the constant itch on my stomach drives
me to insanity
whyever smell the forest again
[Music]
three mother don't do that it was easier
[Music]
the aroma of snake fruit and banana a
sort of silver lining
[Music]
I'm gaining weight and feeling stronger
I can stretch my limbs to climb again
they try to simulate the forest honey
hidden and smooth logs miniature
downpours Li cheese-stuffed and Ryan's
my teeth can't puncture my heart aches
last year but I yearn for the forest
where are they taking me now I awake
under a disorienting prisms like a swarm
of familiar smells sends me into a shock
wild blood rushes through my body
Hanan water
heavy rain
for others
boundless
[Music]
[Applause]
I wonder how long the forest war remains
standing
how long will they let me stay
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]